Democratic presidential candidate Robert O'Rourke,
known to many as Beto O'Rourke has exited
the presidential race.
He's been most recently polling just under
2% on average.
This is pretty logical.
Beto has not gotten traction like many other
candidates.
He's not gotten traction.
He's decided to exit the race because he recognizes
that quote.
We do not have the means to pursue this campaign
successfully.
Nothing to laugh at.
He's recognizing something that other candidates
are either not recognizing or not willing
to accept publicly.
Now, Donald Trump immediately continuing with
his dog rhetoric saying that Beto has quit
like a dog, which doesn't really make any
sense.
If anything, it confirms Donald Trump doesn't
really know anything about dogs.
Dogs, certainly not known for the trait of
quitting things.
In fact, the word dog [inaudible], meaning
having tenacity or persistence suggest the
opposite.
Although I have no idea.
I know that dog had contains dog, but I have
no idea if the etymology is actually from
the word dog.
Anyway, maybe that's me making a joke.
Maybe it's not.
If it works, then by all means, dog had meaning
having tenacity.
How weird is it though?
What's going on with Donald Trump and dogs?
ISIS leader, Abu Bakr al-Baghdadi died like
a dog according to Trump.
Not sure how many dog deaths Trump has witnessed.
Maybe something to look into.
Beto or Roark quit like a dog.
Just very strange dog imagery.
Now that Donald Trump changed his residency
to Florida, the headlines could be Florida
man screams at presidential candidate about
dogs and it would be, I sort of accurate the
upside to Trump using dog as his newest insult
is that he's far less likely to misspell it
when he tweets about it.
I don't think that this is all bad though.
A Beto O'Rourke getting out.
I have been saying for several weeks.
It's time to start, uh, trimming down the
field and getting some of the people that
don't have a shot out of the race.
I would love to see a better or work specifically,
as I've said before, go back to Texas and
challenge Republican Senator John Cornyn for
the Senate seat.
Even if he can't defeat corn, I don't know,
maybe he could, but even if he can't, uh,
forcing Republicans to have to spend a bunch
of money in that race would be a really great
thing.
And speaking of which, there are several people
polling around 2% the way Beto O'Rourke has
been, who should also quit.
Delaney is at 0.3% I don't even know if he's
still running.
I thought maybe he did drop out Marianne Williamson's
at 0.4% she should go who?
Leon Castro sadly, because I think he's actually
a much better candidate than a lot of the
others pulling nothing is that 0.6% probably
time for him to leave Bennett again.
I thought Bennett was out.
I guess he's still in.
He's at 0.7% Tom Stier at just under 1% is
truly an annoying annoyance.
Cory Booker and Tulsi Gobert at 2% time to
go guys, it's over.
And then Amy Klobuchar and Andrew Yang between
two and a half and 3% they're probably ending
soon, but they can maybe justify staying for
one more debate because they are, listen,
three is not that far from five and then you're
in Kameliya territory so maybe they can justify
staying in.
Notably in the last week, this is just a week,
but in the last week, Bernie back up, Joe
Biden back up and Elizabeth Warren down sort
of reversing the recent trends.
It's good not to go too far into analyzing
the ways polls move in just one week.
Uh, because this is a long race.
Currently we have nine people qualified for
the fifth debate.
That's later this month.
On November 20th, we have uh, gabardine Castro
pending qualification.
If they can get the polling they need, they've
hit their fundraising requirements.
So that's that.
I applaud Beto for being realistic and doing
what makes sense.
And I would like to see them go back to Texas
and at least fight for the Senate seat currently
held by John Cornyn.
Let me know if you think that's a good idea.
I'm on Twitter at de Pacman.
Follow me on Twitter.
I'm very close to 100,000 followers and it
would be amazing to reach that completely
arbitrary and meaningless round number so
that then we can try to reach some larger
arbitrary round number.
Follow me
on
twitter@dpacmanandfollowtheshowontwitteratdavidpakmanshowthedavidpakmanshowatdavidpakman.com
[inaudible] the
David Pakman